99% fiabilité oui mais non non non mais
c'est pas mal mais alors juste pour
récapituler là sur le petit cadran quand
il ya un plus c'est sûr ça veut dire
enceinte
oui logique oui mais attendez oui je
passe quelqu'un tomber à l'eau oui
monsieur whisky oui alors moi je vous
explique je prends at il dit donc
vraiment il doit y avoir une erreur oui
ça m'arrive de temps en temps ça vous
arrive jamais à vous dire quelque chose
monsieur non mais écoutez je peux pas me
permettre d'avoir un enfant maintenant
vous comprenez ça on n'a pas le temps on
n'a pas de fric on n'a même pas de place
quoi oui ben oui je patiente lui
permettre de juger qu'un truc moi je
suis enceinte
on est en alerte
un astéroïde se dirige tout droit vers
le 53 rue garibaldi d'après les calculs
de la nasa le metteur devrait percuté le
couple de 18 mois une semaine deux jours
7h21 certains experts annoncent déjà la
fin de leur vie ôtée coûte la fin de
leur vie sociale professionnelle et
sexuelle
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment très très contente
allô oui non écoutez je suis désolé je
viens juste de l'apprendre
mais non
qu'est ce qu'on fait
[Musique]
paris si vous n'avez qu'un mot à me dire
et on dévie sa trajectoire
on en a jamais parlé entre nous mais je
sais pas mais là il ya un point qui se
déplace vraiment très bien donc braqués
les rayons sur la cible 1
général on dirait que la cible nous
envoie un signal on a tout essayé les
chiffres n'obéissent à aucune
combinaison logique impossible de
dégager un message cohérent
ça ressemble une menace déployer le
dispositif non non attendez attendez ça
va trop vite à prendre aucun risque à
chaque minute compte
je crois que j'ai craqué le truc pardon
général photos rien double décimètre
tenez ça peut sembler way
ce titre vient des points
ollier les pompes c'est à dire voyez
comme dans un jeu astrapi
[Musique]
ok ce que vous décidez
vim non mon général je crois que c'est
le symbole universel de la paix l'équipe
à c'est le symbole universel de l'appel
du général
c'est ça il vit en paix aux âmes des
choix est vraiment que c'est une vue
bois général on a un visuel
oh mon dieu tu y en a plusieurs
non c'est une blague eric un regard des
envois way
félicitations vous n'êtes plus seuls
trop chou
revenez la série top up
[Musique]